sitting in an eye hospital
often we have ideas but we have no clue
whom to ask
but honestly now we know that there is a
team at msr that we can reach out
saying that hey here is a problem we
think this warrants attention do you
think you guys can solve it and
we found that work really well so this
kind of a collaboration is i think a
phenomenal impact that this project has
brought together
and we hope that
together we'll be able to come up with
few more solutions that can
align with our founders dream of
eliminating needless blindness from
india
welcome to the microsoft research india
podcast where we explore cutting edge
research that's impacting technology and
society
[Music]
i'm your host sridhar verantham
[Music]
keratoconus is a severe eye disease that
affects the cornea causing it to become
thin and develop a conical bulge
keratoconus if undiagnosed and untreated
can lead to partial or complete
blindness in people affected by it
however the equipment needed to diagnose
keratoconus is expensive and
non-portable which makes early detection
of keratoconus inaccessible to large
populations in low and middle income
countries
this makes it a leading cause for
partial or complete blindness among such
populations
doctors from the shankara high hospital
bengaluru
and researchers from microsoft research
india have been working together to
develop smart kc a low-cost and portable
diagnostic system that can enable early
detection and mitigation of keratoconus
join us as we speak to dr kaushik murali
from shankara hospital and dr mohit jain
from microsoft research india
[Music]
so dr kaushik and mohit welcome to
the podcast hi sridhar hi sritha
pleasure to be here
it's our pleasure to host you dr kaushik
and
for me this is going to be a really
interesting podcast for a couple of
reasons one is that
the topic itself is kind of so far
afield from what i normally hear at
microsoft research
and the second is i think you're the
first guest we're having on the
podcast who's actually not part of msr
so basically a collaborator so this is
really exciting for me
so let me jump right into this um we're
going to be talking about something
called keratoconus
so could you educate us a little bit as
to what keratoconus actually is and what
its impact is
so imagine that you were a 14 year old
who was essentially
nearsighted
you wore glasses and you were able to
see
but with passing time your vision became
more distorted
rather than being blurred which is what
you would have expected if just your
minus bar kept increasing especially for
distance
and to add to your misery you started
seeing more glare and more halos at
night time
words that you started to read had
shadows around them or even started to
look double
this essentially is the world of a
person with keratoconus
literally it means cone-shaped
keratoconus is a condition of the cornea
which is the transparent front part of
the eye similar to your watch glass
where instead of it normally retaining
its dome shape it is characterized by
progressive thinning and weakening of
the central part what we call as a
stroma
and this makes the cornea take on a
conical shape
in a few this can actually even progress
beyond what i described where the
central cornea over time becomes card
and the person could no longer be
corrected which is optical devices like
a glass or a contact lens but may
actually end up requiring a corneal
transplant
i see and what are the causes for this
so there have been very many causes that
have been attributed so it's thought to
be multifactorial
so this again
makes it a little tricky in terms of us
not being able to prevent the condition
so to speak but multiple risk factors
are known ultraviolet exposure chronic
allergies
habitual eye rubber is thought to
be more prone for this
essentially you end up seeing it more
during the pubertal age group and more
in men i see
and uh how widespread is this problem
really
because frankly uh i am of course a very
as layer person as you can get
and i hadn't really heard of
eye disease called keratoconus until i
uh spoke to mohit at some point and then
of course after reading papers and so on
but what is the extent of the issue and
is it really that widespread
problem
so unlike most other conditions there is
no real population based way where we
have screened every household to arrive
at numbers but largely we base our
estimation on small surveys that have
been done
across different parts of the world
based on this we estimate that it is
approximately affecting about one in two
thousand individuals
so in the u.s for example it is thought
to affect almost about 55 people in
about 100 000
who had been diagnosed with keratoconus
but
in countries like india it is thought to
be more widespread so there was actually
a survey in central india where they
found
almost 2 300 people out of 100 000
people being
affected with keratoconus so the numbers
are quite large
and again all of this
could be underestimated simply because
we don't have enough
ability to screen
and what makes this number even scarier
is this is a disease that typically
affects people between the age group of
10 and 25
so once they're affected and they're
progressively going to have their vision
come down
they're going to spend most of their
productive years not being able to see
clearly
okay that is kind of scary
i would just like to add to that is that
there is actually a combination of
demographics genetic and weather
condition which makes india a really
good host for this disease so apparently
indian population tend to have a thinner
and steeper cornea to begin with and
moreover the hot and humid climate of
india
actually contribute towards greater
corners because it causes eye irritation
which leads to frequent rubbing of the
eye and that can actually start the
process of distortion of the cornea
okay so that just made the problem sound
a little scarier because there are these
conditions that cannot be altered right
i mean
climate and stuff like that we can't
really change
um okay dr so uh you know so this is
basically a well-established and
recognized disease right so what are the
barriers and hurdles actually to
effective diagnosis and treatment of
this disease
so you need any health intervention the
barriers typically are availability
accessibility and affordability
and when you look at a condition like
keratoconus it is all these barriers
actually again come into play
so the clinical gold standard for
diagnosing keratoconus essentially
entails us being able to map the
curvature of the corneal surface
using a technique known as corneal
topography
so here we either use something called
as a placido base where you
project a
disk kind of structure onto the cornea
and capture an image using
tomographers
or you use certain other technology to
map out the surface of the cornea both
the anterior and the posterior surface
but all these devices by and large are
non-portable and are expensive
and these are typically available again
at secondary or tertiary eye hospitals
india is a land of diversity we have
some of the best health care in cities
like bangalore where we are sitting and
doing this recording while you move
about 150 200 kilometers away it's a
completely different world out there
the cost of each of these tests again
makes this diagnosis very inaccessible
to large
sections of population not only in india
but in similar middle and low income
countries
and to add to this you have the bogey of
the pandemic so with government 19 and
play the last two years with
restrictions on travel it has become
very difficult for young children to
actually undergo annual eye exams where
we could have even proactively tried to
pick up some of these conditions
okay all right
mohit let me bring you in here i'm
curious as to what microsoft research is
doing as part of this particular
research collaboration right because
keratoconus
sounds very very far afield from
microsoft research's typical computer
science focus
so i think one of the key pillars of msr
india is societal impact
so if we can develop a diagnostic tool
which can save even a handful of
children getting blind we think it has
huge societal impact and microsoft
research india completely i think
supports such kind of technological
solutions
with respect to the computer science
research lab so we have developed a
solution which actually uses cutting
edge
ai especially in the field of image
processing and and then also we have
developed a full end-to-end system so if
there are like enough computer science
research problem really hard ones that
we actually solve as part of this
research collaboration
okay so that's a good lead in to me
to talk a little bit about the solution
that's been developed here
yeah so i think the solution has
actually three core components uh so the
first component is actually a placebo
disk like what dr kaushik said that like
there has to be something which projects
concentric rings over the cornea so we
actually 3d printed
a placido disk so we actually attach
that
procedure to the to the back of a
smartphone camera and then capture an
image of the cornea with the placido
projected over the cornea of a human and
the second component we have is actually
a smartphone app which has inbuilt ai in
it so in real time it actually helps the
person who is capturing the image to
actually get a perfect image because i
think one of the core
design principles that we had while
while working on this was to make sure
that anyone can use this app to actually
diagnose okay we don't want like medical
technician to to be only be able to use
it okay so there is some kind of a
assistance to to help capture a perfect
image of the eye and the third then we
have like an image processing pipeline
which which takes this captured image as
input and converts that into corneal
topography heat maps so basically it
gives a curvature heat map which tells
you like what is the curvature at each
point of the cornea and that is the kind
of output that you also get from a
medical grade corneal topographer
so
the way you explain it sounds very
simple but i'm sure there were a bunch
of challenges while
you know both
shankara and
msr was doing the research can you give
me a sense of what kind of challenges
you faced
yes i think the most trickiest part of
this project was to actually do it in a
portable setting so right now the
corneal topographer that that is like a
ten thousand dollar device which is
there in sankra hospital there is
actually a headrest and a chin rest so
basically your
your whole face like the patient face is
very very stable and hence the the image
capture process is fairly easy apart
from that the the topographer has a lot
of specific hardware for example it has
a specific hardware to determine how far
is the eye from the camera so which is
actually called as a working distance
and getting that parameter right is very
crucial like even a few millimeters of
actually uh predicting that value wrong
can actually completely change the
generated heat map so we have to
actually design a very innovative
solution to figure out this working
distance directly just from the captured
image and the second part was that like
we actually did a lot of iteration on
the presidio disk and also on the ai
assistance which was actually running on
the smartphone
to actually help capture the best image
even without any kind of a support
system in place like without any
headrest or chin rest
dr kaushik
was there anything you wanted to add to
that in terms of challenges from a
medical point of view
so from the medical point of view uh we
are
people of habit
when i say that
there is certain things that we are
comfortable about and certain things
that puts us off
so one of the key challenges we gave to
the msr team was saying that the
interface and reports had to be similar
to what we were used to seeing
so i think the challenge also came to
the team in terms of ensuring that the
heat maps were similar to the heat maps
that we were used to seeing using a
regular topographer and how we actually
were able to match with it so the minute
we were able to get that kind of
familiarity built in
we found our doctors also being able to
accept it much better
and
once that was done then automatically
the learning curve
that came in in terms of using the
device or interpreting the images came
down very very
fast so we were able to adapt to this
much faster we were even able to get
some of our colleagues from other units
to read these heat maps that we
generated just to validate it
because we were also concerned saying
that when you are putting it out as a
screening device you should end up
overestimating the disease
because there is a indirect cause to a
person and
imagine the psychological impact to a
parent if you tell them your young child
may have a possible problem so we didn't
want to do that so we were very finicky
about the validation so it went through
multiple iterations
almost to the effect that
mohit and his team could have lunch on a
thursday only after they finished the
call with us
to add to that this is actually a very
crucial point initially what we were
thinking so there are like these two
values called as sensitivity and
specificity so just to give you uh some
context here sensitivity is actually
if if the person has keratoconus are we
able to diagnose it as correct on this
so that's the sensitivity specificity is
that like if the person does not have
protocols are we actually even
diagnosing that correctly so we were
thinking that we need to get like really
high sensitivity we cannot leave anyone
who has keratoconus undiagnosed but we
can have low specificity that even
someone who does not have ketogenic we
can say that he or she has cryptoconus
and still it's okay because then he or
she will actually go to a doctor and get
checked up maybe for a second time and
then it will be diagnosed that he or she
does not have criticism but doctor
kosciek uh specifically was really
against that okay so he actually made a
problem statement harder saying that we
want both sensitivity and specificity to
be above 92 percent okay because because
he does not want like parents to be
unnecessarily worrying that they're
that their kid who is like in his teens
right now and he has like this very
serious eye condition so hence we
actually have to light you up as what dr
kaushik said like you have to go through
multiple iterations even like get the
specificity right and right now i think
we are at a stage where we have like
both the numbers which are above 94
percent for a small trial that we did
with sankra with more than 100 uh
patients and in future we plan to
actually extend that trial and i can do
it in many more patients
[Music]
a question for
both you mohith as well as dr kaushik so
whoever wants to answer it
you know you just
put out some numbers there in terms of
percentages right
to say that
this solution works well
but typically these need to be tagged
against some kind of industry benchmark
or some kind of medical benchmark given
the
established machines and equipment
already
that that are being already used right
so how does uh this smart kc
stack up against those
so
once the msr team had come up with a
complete solution and
they had tested in their lab the
reliability of the solution so to speak
with the images that they had with them
we then applied to our ethics committee
for a prospective study so we enrolled
subjects coming to our hospital
and we had them get their cornea image
with the smart kc as well as with the
placido based topography system that we
have in a hospital that we would
typically have used in any case
one index that the device that we use in
the hospital uses to identify
keratoconus
is an index called as the percentage
probability of keratoconus or the ppk
value
this if it is more than 45 percent is
suppose it supposed to indicate the
presence of keratoconus
so what we found was with the smart kc
the sensitivity of ppk value
was 94.1 percent and the specificity was
100
which was pretty comparable to what we
had with our other device
which stood at about 94.1 percent
sensitivity and 95.5 percent specificity
more importantly
whenever you use any device as a
screening tool is how repeatable is it
and how is the integrator agreement if
two different people use the same device
on the same person
are they actually reading it out the
same
so again in this we found
those indices to be really really high
so there's something called as the
cohen's kappa value
this was about 0.94 for our tool which
compared to 0.96 for the device that we
have in the hospital this essentially
indicates a fair agreement between two
experts diagnosing keratoconus based on
the images that we are generating using
the smart kc
wow that's impressive
um i had another question
you know whenever i went into
uh an eye hospital
there always seems to be somebody who's
well trained as a technician operating
various machines how does it work with
this i mean do you need any specific
training on smart kc how intensive is
that and who are there any particular
types of people you look for or some
kind of skill level in people who can
operate a smart kc unit
so currently most of the data that was
collected
has been done by our optometry interns
at the chakra college of optometry
so the skill set that was required was
not very high
like mohit mentioned earlier there is
some assistant in terms of even how you
can capture an image so the eventual
end point for us would be this being
used at a peripheral vision center or at
some
primary health center as a part of a
school screening program
where a lay person can pick up this
device and actually capture an image
and at least be able to counsel the
person about
them having to have a further
examination
so the training that would probably be
required is largely in terms of what the
condition that they are screening for
and what the next action needs to be
so it's more counseling skill i would
say rather than anything really
technical the machine does it all it
gives them a heat map it tells them what
the value is
it kind of literally puts up a red flag
saying boss be careful there is a
problem here
so i'm guessing that's all part of
the technology that's been built into it
say you know various uh guard rails to
ensure that whoever is operating it is
doing it in the right way mohit
yes yes raiser so basically in the
latest version of the app what we have
done is that like the
operator whoever is actually capturing
the image he or she doesn't even have to
click the capture button so you just
have to place the uh the smart kc on a
patient i and it automatically
tries to align it appropriately with the
eye and once the alignment is right once
the image does not have any kind of a
blur and the focus is appropriate the
light is fine it automatically captures
three images so that actually
makes the process really easy for the
operator and he or she does like needs
to go through very minimal training
to get up and running with the device
nice
and
you know we've referred earlier to the
cost of
current machines that are there that are
used in eye hospitals and so on right
and one of the
guiding principles behind
developing smart kc was for something to
be portable inexpensive and easy to use
in the field
one thing that i don't think we've
spoken about yet is actually how
inexpensive smart kc is
and i'm also curious to find out whether
the equipment that you use needs to be
high and for example do you need a
high-end mobile phone to do it and how
does the whole system work
yes so currently for developing our
research prototype we actually end up
spending like almost like 33 dollar is
the amount that we are underspending
making the device okay apart from the
smartphone the smartphone that we are
using is a slightly high end one so it
is around like a 400 device that we have
used uh for the current prototype uh but
moving ahead we are actually for the
next round of data collection with
sankra hospital we are actually trying
out with like three different uh devices
and uh starting from like a hundred
dollar device 200 device and a 300
device so that we can actually see that
with whether it works on all the devices
however based on our current uh work we
hypothesize that actually it can work on
any standard smartphone it just needs a
decent camera by the way nowadays even a
very hundred dollar device have like a
20 megapixel camera so i think that's
already taken care by the by the most of
the latest smartphone
so i think uh yeah it it should ideally
work in all of them but we will only
know for sure once we have the second
round of testing
cool
uh
so you know given that you've put in so
much work and you've come up with
something that sounds like a fantastic
solution
what kind of impact do you think
smart casey can have or what kind of
impact do you hope smart kc will have
so right now actually we have discussed
a few use cases with dr kosciek and i
think the most interesting use case is
what dr costing initially referred to is
the teacher use case the biggest impact
smart case he could have is that let's
say
all the teachers in india uh even the
rural one urban one semi-auburn or even
like low-income community even in urban
india they have access to smart kc and
every year maybe twice a year or thrice
a year they screen every children in
their school for keratoconus and because
the numbers are really high the numbers
are like two to three children out of
every 100 children
will have keratoconus so with that in
mind we should be able to get like a few
cases from every school so if these are
diagnosed very early on then there is a
very very high likelihood that they
could have been treated just by simple
glasses or contact lens and they don't
have to go through surgery or corneal
transplant or blindness which is the
worst case situation by the way i think
earlier uh when we were talking about
conjunct transplant so globally 27
percent of the corneal transplant
happens to actually fix keratoconus so
so it is it is a very deadly disease
so i'm going to take off on a tangent
i'm actually going to look beyond just
this particular solution so although i'm
here representing shankara at this
podcast
a couple of my colleagues actually did a
deep dive into this entire solution dr
anand and pallavi were there
as well as some of our faculty from the
college of optometry
uh what this project has actually
impacted us is to think of how we can
actually leverage technology sitting in
an eye hospital
often we have ideas but we have no clue
whom to ask but honestly now we know
that there is a team at msr that we can
reach out
saying that hey here is a problem we
think this warrants attention do you
think you guys can solve it and
we found that work really well so this
ability to collaborate between complete
extremes of people
uh one and your medical specialist who
have no clue about what engineering is
today i think knows more optometry than
even i do
so they actually borrowed textbooks from
us to read
so this kind of a collaboration is i
think a phenomenal impact that this
project has brought together
and we hope that
together we'll be able to come up with
few more solutions that can
align with our founders dream of
eliminating needless blindness from
india
nice congratulations mohit thank you
i'll come to you for my next eye test
you will soon start referring to him as
doctor
all right i think i've got all the
information that i
really wanted but one thing is
you know if
people
want to adopt smart casey and they want
to take it out there in the field
what do they need to do and are there
any particular requirements or criteria
that they need to
fulfill etc i mean how do people get
hold of this
so right now we we have actually made
everything open source so even the 3d
print for the placido disk so the stl
file of that is open source anyone can
download it and like just like you take
a printout you can actually go to a
makerspace and get a 3d print of that
even the app which is actually ai
assisted app which is running on the
smartphone we have only written it for
an android phone so you can actually
download it and you can install it on
your android phone and connect that uh
smart kc plc attachment and can click an
image of i the image processing pipeline
code is also completely open so so you
the collected image you can then run on
it to actually generate the corneal
topography heat map uh so that is that
is the current state uh going ahead we
are actually putting everything on the
cloud so that once you have the residual
disk and you capture an image it
automatically goes to the cloud and
gives you the final output
excellent so i will add links to various
things onto the podcast page once we're
done with this
dr kaushik
any final thoughts before we close this
podcast
so quite often we look at
challenges as challenges but
i think
essentially this collaboration has
looked at
an opportunity and how we can actually
work on it
all it required was to put some method
to the madness and
what came up as one discussion is today
i think turned out into three different
projects that are currently underway
so this is something that is a potential
it would be lovely if similar technology
companies can collaborate with the
medical institutions across india
we don't have to look elsewhere for
solutions it's all here
it's up to us to figure it out and run
with it
that's a great note to end the podcast
on so once again thank you so much dr
kaushik and
dr mohit thank you so much
thank you
[Music]